something kind of crazy happened last
weekend the internet descended upon an
online canvas of roughly 4 million
pixels
millions of people took part in the
great social experiment known as r
place art was made wars were fought and
at its peak it completely took over
twitch whether you missed it or made it
here's how it all happened
all right guys i spent a fairly large
portion of my weekend watching this
mainly because i found it absolutely
fascinating but also because i knew i'd
be making this video so if you do enjoy
it and you haven't subscribed yet please
consider doing so we're almost at 2
million subscribers and you could help
us get there all right then if you're
sitting comfortably let's get started
the story begins with a software
engineer called josh wardle josh is a
former product manager at reddit in 2015
he helped create the social experiment
game called the button which launched on
april fool's day reddit users were
presented with a button which if press
would reset a 60 second timer sounds
pretty simple but it absolutely
captivated reddit at the time and then
on april fool's day 2017 he followed it
up with something even greater a
subreddit called r slash place otherwise
known simply as place oh and he's also
been known more recently as the guy who
created wordle yes as in
word he's been a busy bloke going back
to place though the idea was simple
there was a large white canvas in which
users could change the color of one
pixel every 5 to 20 minutes for the next
three days over a million reddit users
from hundreds of different communities
piled onto the canvas to add their
pixels what started out as crude
drawings quickly evolved into elaborate
pixel art created and maintained by
organized teams of people but very
quickly people realized that place
wasn't just about creating art you had
to defend it because anyone could change
a pixel if you wanted your art to stay
intact you and your team had to be on
high alert now we're not going into
depth here about what happened after
other channels have done that very well
over the years all you need to know
though is that after 72 hours when this
thing ended people thought that was the
end of place forever josh wardle and
reddick gave no indication that place
would be returning and so it became
internet folklore i somehow missed all
of this at the time and it became almost
mythical to me but five years later last
friday to be exact our slash place
returned on april fool's day once again
and the internet lost its [ __ ] everyone
and their mum piled onto the canvas
including some of the biggest twitch
streamers on the planet and almost
immediately there were some recognizable
features from the original place the
germans immediately started creating
their canvas spanning flag and just like
last time a group who called themselves
the blue corner did what their name was
suggest and kept an entire corner blue
the ominous black voids began to appear
in pockets too threatening to swallow
communities whole beautiful artwork
began to pop up around the canvas there
were some stunning recreations of famous
paintings by the dutch and there was
also the ongoing hilarity of canada not
being able to get their leaf right for
pretty much the duration of the event
there was even a group of among us fans
who were hell-bent on hiding their
characters in everyone else's art one
favorite of mine was the group that made
a working qr code which led people to
get rick rolled there was a lot of
impressive stuff out there but the
question was how long was it gonna last
there was always gonna be random people
looking to grief someone's art but by
far the biggest threat on the canvas
were streamers and their armies of
followers it's difficult to take over an
area by yourself the five-minute
cooldown between placing pixels means
that large groups of people were
extremely powerful they could create or
destroy in the blink of an eye when it
came to destruction one name in
particular seemed to stand out xqc he
would lead his followers to create voids
of black pixels that would stream across
the cannabis swallowing anything in its
way avoid it avoid it
up
into this yep yeah chad knows how to do
it i don't say anything guys next push
next push
and at peak xqc chaos he broke his own
personal streaming record to reach an
astounding 233
000 concurrent viewers and to be fair he
did create some pretty cool pieces of
art with his community and really played
the role of villain on the canvas quite
well classic hqc stuff now at times the
destruction we've talked about was far
more targeted looking across the canvas
you could see a lot of national flags
areas claimed by people for their
country these flags became the staging
grounds for huge battles like when xqc
and his viewers tried to take on
turkey's flag because hassan refused to
ally with him he is too big for his
britches he's gonna take down turkey i
don't think so dude he doesn't want the
smoke from the turkish army to come
amazingly the turkish community managed
to defend their flag and push back xqc's
attack but the greatest battle was yet
to come over the course of the weekend
the canvas had its size periodically
increased at the beginning of the third
expansion the french community quickly
took up a large corner for their
national flag on top of being accused of
hogging too much space on the canvas the
french were also accused by spanish
streamers of using bots this argument
quickly devolved into literal world war
3. we attacked the russia because you
you type ratio of the french flag like
it's not respectful okay okay listen to
me it's not respectful to use scripts
and bots don't use scripts
oh my god no i have two clips of you
using excuse me but the script is
uh i'm starting world war three right
now with the french in spain but as well
you know i love you okay
okay bye all right wait you don't wanna
ask if i'm gonna die
bye the battle lines were drawn on the
one side the french community hundreds
of thousands of them led by their most
prominent streamers on the other the
spanish were backed by big streamers
like miz kif and hassan even xqc stopped
his chaos to join in the battle took
place on the border between the french
flag and the hezbollah mural the goal
was simple give hezbollah some legs and
shoes thereby claiming a large chunk of
the french territory
but despite the best efforts of the
attackers the french defended their flag
there were more accusations of them
botting especially because some of the
accounts they were using seem to be very
new but reddit is an american site it is
plausible that the french viewers simply
created fresh accounts for the occasion
and this was just one battle in a larger
war a heat map posted to reddit of the
area shows just how much activity
occurred there with the creator claiming
over 1 million users took part in this
war alone and that was just one
storyline in one corner of the map all
over the canvas there were countless
battles storylines and creations going
on between communities big and small the
creators of place had told everyone that
the whole thing would end on monday the
4th of april but they didn't specify
exactly when or how it would happen i
myself was sat there doing some repairs
on the irish flag when suddenly i
realized i could now only place white
tiles no more color and slowly it began
to dawn on everyone the creators had
made it so that they weren't going to
turn the canvas back into white again we
were going to do it for them at first
there was a lot of confusion what the is
happening with france
that is insane everything is white
no you can only put white every every
every line that's good take france
oh
my god wait so then you can see which
spots are botted oh i mean france is
getting white very fast
france is like deleting himself
france is deleting itself in the space
of an hour millions of pixels and days
of work had been wiped out it was quite
poetic seeing it return back to a white
canvas once again all right chad in the
middle keep it up
this was a lot of fun man this was this
was crazy this was madness yeah also i i
liked it only that's like five days it
doesn't extend people don't don't
it was the perfect perfect length yeah i
agree
this might have been one of the greatest
streaming events ever i highly recommend
interactive maps like this one if you
want to get detailed stories about every
inch of the canvas but for me that was
the big picture in all of its pixelated
glory so what did this social experiment
teach us well not to sound too softy but
people can do dope things if they work
together they can also be incredibly
destructive and people will go to
literal world war three on a canvas to
defend a few pixels what does all of
that mean i don't know people are
probably writing video essays about the
whole thing as i speak but for now it
was strange it was shocking it was fun
and i think for many people it was great
to feel a part of something to feel if
only for a weekend that they had a place
our place
you know what rick roll means
you know i'm never gonna give you up
never gonna let you down
you had the phrase before
well i mean see now i feel like i should
explain it but it's like
which is a process of tricking someone
into watching rick astley's 1986
music video never going to give you up